hey Oscar Marez welcome and welcome my
intro everybody's back welcome to the
tea party simulator I'm a female haha
okay I got a female hand now all right
well this is [ __ ] great just gonna
[ __ ] the floor for a bit sorry excuse me
well like smack everyone's [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] it crashed damn it why is my
pinky finger just [ __ ] me what do you
like what do you want why is the pinky
finger being such a [ __ ] oh it's
because it's tea of course or I'm gonna
finger this Teddy beer
I love finger it good sorry oh we can go
over here that makes sense
hello Irish hat high-five Irish hat I
bring you Irish hat and I put you on the
beer you [ __ ] pervert stop it stop
stop [ __ ] that hat
what is it Kat I'll do it ah this should
hurt but I like it
well I can't stop love you want me to
[ __ ] just rip everything up it's not
what you want what do you want from me
what is happening oh the tea got aborted
alright
that's kind of harsh well at least all
right you know what let's actually try
to play this game it's slipping out of
my hand a bit oh there you go this is
how it sorry I didn't this is how we'd
pour tea in Sweden whoops
Teddy likes to have a salman with his
[ __ ]
Sally we'll have to wait here sit dear
Sally Jay stuck what was that oh my god
what does [ __ ] happened what was i what
was that
Teddy what was that where do you come
from don't ever been so scared in my
life
Sally Sally doesn't look Sal is dad you
don't want Teddy and Sally to be
together well tough [ __ ] Sally's dad
supposed to be a calm game a calm game
hello Teddy let's make some tea shall be
yes Teddy what your name is not Teddy
what's your name then Teddy well you're
like when I touch you teddy
would you like me to finger you teddy oh
sorry
all right teddy would you like me to
stick this finger up your bum with that
pay attention is that we make sweet and
TE Travis fix your forehead all those
bubbles so I watch you carefully pick
and suck my ass there you go what else
you want some biscuits are you greedy
son of a [ __ ] what you want to slice a
cake
no problem laughs Wanda let's get some
cake there you go nice piece of cake the
tea it says it doesn't have tea what are
you talking about turn up for what get
I'm sorry about fingering you earlier I
hope you don't mind what kind of [ __ ]
weirdo doesn't one tea oh the tea is in
here
of course my bad ad just gonna [ __ ]
get it up and out ah I don't know how I
pick that up how is that not te I don't
even want to live in a world where you
good grief are you drunk or something
wow that's offensive to drunk people
alright we have to dip it or like there
we go alright there you go have a cookie
[ __ ] now for cutting the cake I need
that salad it doesn't work what kind of
cheap Chinese fish is this look at what
pouring the tea like a pout what that's
amazing a little did I pull that off
imma cut you you want to slice [ __ ]
that's right I'll give you a plate [ __ ]
oh no he died are you serious are you
[ __ ] kidding me
who dies from a tea party
god dammit [ __ ] fancy-pants ass oh
[ __ ] sorry
hahaha I was gonna throw it to the side
alright can we cut the cake this one
what's the point of the jello if you can
hello if you're not I mean haha I did it
and I tea party victory whoa alright so
that was just another simulator game huh
well I hope you enjoyed yourself I had
like this video if you enjoy watching
booze yes
tickle my bottle anything you say I
shall do
you